welcome everyone uh to this lightning
talk we talk about
the uh how to utilize word of many exam
creating posting to identify analyze and
predict errors in the machine edit
manufacturing industry
so uh first I will go through some
points regarding what are we trying to
solve and what's about the industry and
what algorithms did we use and what was
the real world impact
so this is the dental milling machine I
don't know if how many of you have been
to the dental lab before whenever you
get braces these machines print out your
teeth structure and the D shape builds
those machines
and these machines have a lot of
Maintenance to do and they are basically
Supply to dental labs
and the on the on the right side you
could see a distribution of the data
that they collect so these these
machines are data heavy with lots of
data flowing into them
at every day whenever the machine is
being used
so what are we trying to solve so for a
given machine
and this could be any machine but for
our case this could be a dental milling
machine we are trying to solve using all
the data stored can we uh first thing is
prognosis
so basically I call these three piece
first B is prognosis can we identify or
analyze the machine errors
then prevent can we prevent it can the
machine areas be prevented
and predict can future errors based on a
machine could be predicted
now this problem is a very well known
one in the in the in in the car industry
but in this in our case for the billing
industry this is one of a kind property
how can we use data science and AI to
to perform these three p's
so these are these are something about
the stats of the computer aided
manufacturing industry and sometimes the
question would come up why why
complicate things using AI or data
science to
like in the machine and these are some
points so basically if we apply these
three p's to get information then we
would have a better customer attention
we have a better support system where
instead of calling customer service the
dental lab owner in our case could
easily highlight the problem basically
allow the allow the software to find the
problem and third Point uh
is that this provides this technology
provides the engineers to better design
machines so they can see okay
using these sensor values we have these
many errors so we can build up a new
sensor in the next version
so these can be helpful in these three
points this uh this technology
so now let's talk about the data
bandwidth that we have we have a lot of
sensor and log data as I as I said if
you recall from the slides we had about
80 percent as login sensor data
and what's our outcome to build future
models and explainable models basically
and this is where gradient boosting
comes in the play
and what's the dimensionality so we have
23 columns and as you would see that
this is a typical typical case of class
imbalance where there are lots of Errors
uh there are no errors but lots of no
error sensor values
so and one other problem that we faced
was the sensor data and log data
separate entities they are in no way
related
up to up till this point uh so we we had
to find some way to uh to consolidate
the streaming data and the last point is
there are two variants of the machine so
there's this question of uh how should
we proceed should we build two models or
different machines or one model for each
each version of the machine
or each or or each generation of the
machine and then what's our compute
availability
so these three things were to consider
when using uh word embedding the
ingredient boosting to identify
predict and prevent errors
so the first uh
algorithm that I would like to talk
about are watermelics now word amazings
have been heavily used in a lot of
uh and a lot of different places
but if we talk about log analysis word
embeddings have been used but it's not
that popular
so what do we have we have
we have a lot of word demandings
available we have a lot of log data
available to us
as you can as you could see
and we have to convert that into vectors
that represent meaning
so using word to work a popular
Technique we can convert each error or
each sentence into a low dimensional
Vector that represents meaning
so what's the advantage of of all this
so the first these are some of the
advantages that we found out it was
basically we can identify we can analyze
data we can put unstructured data into
structured data we can build up meaning
in our unstructured log files we can map
out similar days using clustering on
those vectors
so we could say okay on Monday the these
kinds of errors on Tuesday there's these
kind of errors
and then we can also map out the time of
Errors what time are the errors most
active and all these are through the
Clusters we build up clusters and we
could see different uh patches being
made up
and there's a lot more to to utilizing
word remainings in this space and I
would like to point out that the log
data does not contain
the the machine stayed but it also
contains user actions
uh basically how the dentist uses the
machine and how the cat software uh
takes in the commands
so the next model is the gradient
boosting as you could see this is a
working diagram of gradient boosting
trees where they take in model and learn
from its residuals and so on this is an
iterative process and using our 23
column sensor values what we found out
that if we could add in a feature of our
embeddings or using the log data where
we found out we had a way to connect
water buildings and gradient boosting
and we built up an end-to-end ml
training pipeline where we took in log
data took in sensor data
so basically it took an unstructured
data and structured data and
Consolidated it using word embeddings
and applied gradient boosting to it to
predict what sensor values yield and
error or what sensor values do not yield
an error
so this is an end-to-end process that we
have replicated in this industry or
basically for our case in the dental
billing industry
and
so what's the real world impact we see
we now have a way to combine all the
streaming Text data and unstructured
basically the unstructured data and the
tabular data
now this is extremely useful to us
because there are lots of log data
logged every day and there was no way to
make it understandable now we have a way
to make it understandable using a column
as the word remainings in our Canadian
boosting model we could also find out
what what what feature contributes to
the importance of the label so we could
do feature importance to find out what
what what columns are the most important
so this gives us an idea on what to
improve and what not to improve
and we see based on based on our initial
experiments that there is a 10x boost in
our performance in our accuracy
and that is a huge boost in in this area
given that we are consolidating the text
and the and the sensitivity
and the last point and this would be my
closing point is we effectively show how
we could use Ai and data science in the
computer aided manufacturing industry to
identify the three p's and that is it
thanks a lot